[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg
Mittwochabend herzlich willkommen
Norbert Lehmann ist auch dabei für den
Sport
Explosion auf der Krim dort gerät ein
russischer Stützpunkt in Brand und
Moskau droht Schiffe im Schwarzen Meer
anzugreifen
schlank dank Spritze Chancen und Risiken
des neuen appetit-züglers im Kampf
gegenübergewicht
und Sieg für Felix Gall der Österreicher
gewinnt die Königsetappe der Tour de
France Jonas vinegard verteidigt das
Gelbe Trikot und baut die Führung sogar
noch aus
[Musik]
gerade erst stoppte Russland das
Abkommen über die Ausfuhr von
ukrainischem Getreide jetzt geht der
Kreml einen Schritt weiter ab morgen
gelten Schiffe in den betroffenen
Gebieten des Schwarzen Meeres als
mögliche militärische Gegner außerdem
bombardierten die Russen die zweite
Nacht in Folge den wichtigen Hafen in
Odessa Christoph
nahe der Front im Süden russische
Raketenwerfer feiern auf ukrainische
Stellungen ukrainische Raketenwerfer
beschießen russische Truppen
kriegsroutine ein ukrainischer Soldat
sieht die Lage aktuell so
Seminar Luftwaffe Bodentruppen Marine
damit unsere Gegenoffensive klappt
brauchen wir in irgendeinem Bereich
einen Vorteil gegenüber den Russen
momentan aber haben wir ein
militärisches Bad
noch 300 Panzerfahrzeuge mehr dazu etwa
70 F16 Jets damit könnte man etwas
erreichen heißt es heute aus Kiew so
aber ist es vielleicht kein Zufall dass
derzeit besonders viel Zerstörung weit
hinter der Front eingerichtet wird
wie der Explosion auf der besetzten Krim
ist eine der Meldung aus der Nacht
vorgestern die Brücke heute ein
Militärlager der von Moskau unterstützte
Gouverneur bestätigt nur ein Feuer sagt
aber nichts zur Ursache
bisher gibt es keine Opfer Hilfe von
außen ist nicht erforderlich rund um das
Lager im Osten der Krim werden vier
Siedlungen evakuiert 20200 Menschen und
die wichtige Autobahn von Ost nach West
gesperrt
trotzdem alles im Griff so die Botschaft
während auch die Ukraine sich wie schon
bei ähnlichen Zwischenfällen bedeckt
hält die anderen Detonationen aus der
Nacht erschüttern vor allem modessa
russischer Beschuss wie gestern schon
fast alle Raketen schlagen im
Hafengebiet ein Silos und ein Warenhaus
gehen in Flammen auf massive Schäden
aber in der höllischen Nacht wie sie ein
Sprecher nennt kommt offenbar kein
Mensch ums Leben dabei droht die Lage
noch explosiver zu werden für die
Ukraine und ihre Handelspartner Moskau
hat am Abend angekündigt ab morgen
betrachte es alle Schiffe im Schwarzen
Meer als potentielle Gegner
an wen richtet sich diese Drohung alle
Schiffe im Schwarzen Meer als Gegner zu
betrachten
der Präsidentin hat darauf noch nicht
reagiert aber bisher war die Haltung der
Ukraine sehr klar man versuchte
Partner zu finden um das
getreideabkommen
weiterlaufen zu lassen und genau in
diese Partner richtet sich wohl die
Drohung zum Beispiel könnte man sie
dadurch abschrecken Sicherheitsgarantien
für die Frachter und die Ukraine
auszusprechen und ein weiterer Adressat
dürften die Räder sein die
Schiffseigentümer und die Versicherer
nämlich ihnen droht jetzt ab morgen dann
ein Verlust der Schiffe samt Ladung und
dieses Risiko werden wohl weniger
Unternehmer eingehen
vielen Dank für diese Informationen live
aus Odessa Dara Hassan
zur UN-Vollversammlung dort muss sich
Russland heute dafür rechtfertigen das
Millionen Menschen im Norden Syriens
keine internationale Hilfe mehr bekommen
seit vor zehn Tagen das entsprechende
UN-Mandat ausgelaufen ist eine
Verlängerung der Hilfslieferungen hatte
Moskau mit seinem Veto im
Weltsicherheitsrat verhindert die
Blockade trifft vor allem die
nordsyrische Provinz Idlib ein
Rebellengebiet das nicht von Präsident
Assad kontrolliert wird golini atai
berichtet
sie fühlt wie die Schlinge um ihren Hals
langsam zugeht sagt nur abdelbasid
alraui ihre Tochter starb an den Masern
der Sohn ist hörgeschädigt und braucht
Medikamente wie fast alle der vier bis
fünf Millionen Syrer hier ist ihre
Familie auf Hilfe und Lebensmittelpakete
angewiesen die zuletzt immer seltener
wurden jetzt könnte selbst diese wenige
Hilfe versiegen
sie wollen uns langsam töten und selbst
essen und trinken vorenthalten das Assad
Regime hat uns belagert
in der Kinderklinik in der Nähe stellen
sich die Ärzte auf das Schlimmste ein
die Schließung schon jetzt fehlen
Medikamente und Geräte das Damaskus nun
die Hilfe für dieses Gebiet selbst
koordinieren will könnte ihr Todesurteil
bedeuten das wissen sie aus Erfahrung
[Applaus]
werden sich ausbreiten es wird noch mehr
Tote geben die medizinische Versorgung
wird in einer Katastrophe enden
es geht um diese Lebenslinie der einzige
noch offene Grenzübergang zur Türkei
durch den Millionen Menschen im
oppositionsgebiet Hilfe bekommen
vor einer Woche im UN-Sicherheitsrat
Russland engster Verbündeter des
Assad-Regimes beschließt mit seinem Veto
das Ende dieser Hilfe das Ende einer
UN-Resolution die Zivilisten schützen
sollte vor Ersatz Regime
angreifen und aushungern so will
Russland die letzten syrischen
Oppositionellen unter Assets Kontrolle
bringen
[Musik]
Russland und der syrische Regime wissen
dass humanitäre Hilfe als Druckmittel
auf die internationale Gemeinschaft
eingesetzt werden kann um Zugeständnisse
zu bekommen
Zugeständnisse auf Kosten der
schwächsten ein Schachzug der weitere
Flüchtlingsströme auslösen könnte
nach Deutschland vor vier Jahren wurde
der Kassler Regierungspräsident weiter
Lübcke ermordet erschossen von einem
Rechtsextremisten ein
Untersuchungsausschuss wurde eingesetzt
mit dem Ziel aufzuklären ob dieses
Verbrechen zu verhindern gewesen wäre
aber auch mit dem Versprechen ein
gemeinsames Signal gegen rechte Gewalt
zu setzen daraus wurde nichts weil sich
die Parteien nicht einigen konnten gibt
es jetzt mehrere Abschlussberichte
der Mord am Kasseler
Regierungspräsidenten Walter Lübcke
hätte er verhindert werden können dieser
Frage ging ein Untersuchungsausschuss im
hessischen Landtag nach denn zwischen
verurteilte Mörder der den
Sicherheitskräften bekannte
Rechtsextremist Stephan Ernst stand zum
Zeitpunkt der Tat nicht mehr im Fokus
des hessischen Verfassungsschutzes ich
habe alle Sachverständigen und Zeugen
befragt hätten wir die Möglichkeit
gehabt den späteren Mörder Ernst zu
observieren durch den Verfassungsschutz
ihn abzuhören die haben das alle
verneint die haben alle gesagt es gab
keine rechtlichen Möglichkeiten gegen
Ernst vorzugehen anders sieht dass die
Opposition in Hessen und legt deshalb
eigene Abschlussberichte zum U-Ausschuss
vor der hessische Verfassungsschutz habe
total versagt Stefan ernst sei immer
wieder als Neonazi in Erscheinung
getreten als Lübke bei der
Bürgerversammlung in Lohfelden die
Flüchtlingspolitik Angela Merkels
verteidigte war auch Stefan Ernst im
Saal und radikalisierte sich weiter dr
Lübke wurde nach der Bürgerversammlung
auch nicht genügend geschützt dort gab
es Straße und Hetze nicht eine einzige
Anzeige wurde gefertigt das zeigt man
hat die Gefahren augenscheinlich
unterschätzt auch die tausendfach
geteilte Hetze gegen Lübcke im Netz rief
den Verfassungsschutz nicht auf dem Plan
das Lübcke im Fadenkreuz der extremen
Rechten steht hätte 2015 klar sein
müssen ich hätte klar sein müssen als er
Hunderte von Mails voller Hass und Hetze
und Mordphantasien bekam diese
Verantwortung meine Damen und Herren
trifft den Verfassungsschutz und Polizei
den beiden entging dieser Hetzkampagne
gegen Lübcke die demokratischen Parteien
in Hessen sie konnten sich nicht auf
einen gemeinsamen Abschlussbericht
einigen dabei hatte sich das die Familie
des ermordeten Walter Lübcke
ausdrücklich gewünscht
Anfang Oktober wird in Bayern gewählt
die CSU liegt in den Umfragen klarfahren
kämpft aber um die 40% Marke und winkt
jetzt mit verschiedenen Vorschlägen um
die Bürger zu entlasten auf einer
Klausur im Kloster andechsgrenzen sich
Ministerpräsident Söder und CDU-Chef
Merz auch klar von der AFD ab Alexander
Pool berichtet
dass die CSU in der Migrationspolitik
ihre Schwesterpartei mahnt nicht zu weit
zu gehen kommt überraschend der Vorstoß
der CDU das individuelle Asylrecht
abzuschaffen bezeichnet Markus Söder als
spannenden Vorschlag aber tatsächlich
dir wünschen Erträge bringt das glaube
ich ist steht noch offen und natürlich
das muss man auch sagen wir werden eine
fundamentale Änderung die schon eine
Herausforderung wäre Friedrich Merz
verteidigt den Vorstoß offen ja das ist
ein ein wichtiger und guter Beitrag um
ein Problem zu lösen gehen Sie mal davon
aus wenn führende Mitglieder unserer
Fraktion namensbeiträge veröffentlichen
dass ich das vorher weiß soweit so eins
zwei Landtagswahlen hat die Union in
diesem Jahr zu bestreiten die harsche
Kritik an der Bundesregierung hat CDU
und CSU in den Umfragen nicht geholfen
im Gegenteil nutzen allein die AFD umso
deutlicher heute der Versuch Markus
Söders eine rote Linie zu ziehen
mag einen Motiv entspringen ich zeig's
ihnen mal vielleicht
aber am Ende die stabilisiert man die
Demokratie und schwächt unser Land das
er selbst durch seine beinharte Kritik
etwa an den Grünen die AFD gestärkt
haben könnte will Söder nicht hören für
Friedrich Merz geht es um mehr drei
Landtagswahlen in Ostdeutschland alle im
nächsten Jahr überall sehen die Umfragen
die AFD um die 30 Prozent ich werde auch
an die ja an die Vernunft der
Wählerinnen und Wähler appellieren und
auch sehr klar und sehr deutlich sagen
eine Stimme für die AFD ist eine Stimme
für die Ampel und da ist es wieder das
Schreckgespenst der Ampel ob die Wähler
in Ostdeutschland den Appell des
CDU-Chefs überhaupt hören wollen steht
auf einem anderen Blatt
[Applaus]
neue appetit-zügler sind gerade extrem
gefragt viele erhoffen sich damit
endlich Erfolg beim Abnehmen fast 47%
der Frauen hier zu Lande und mehr als
60% der Männer sind übergewichtig
Adipositas also krankhaftes Übergewicht
hat fast jeder fünfte Erwachsene vor
allem an diese Gruppe richtet sich die
neue abnehmen Spritze Weg die ist jetzt
in Deutschland zugelassen Christopher
Heinze
ein Peaks pro Woche und die Kilos
purzeln schon das bewirkt das neue
Medikament wegowi für Menschen mit
chronischer Adipositas jetzt zugelassen
verschreibungspflichtig einfach in der
Handhabung ein Fortschritt für die
betroffenen Patienten denn bislang gab
es keine vergleichbaren Präparate
prinzipiell sind wir alle insgesamt sehr
erfreut dass wir endlich einen
verfügbares Medikament in Deutschland
haben für die Volkskrankheit Adipositas
die wir als chronisch entzündliche
Stoffwechselerkrankung verstehen das ist
ganz ganz wichtig trotz der Wiesener
Wirkung die gesetzlichen Krankenkassen
übernehmen die Kosten für vegowi
zwischen zwei bis 300 € pro Monat nicht
sie berufen sich auf die gesetzlich
festgeschriebene lifestyle-regel die
Lifestyle Regel besagt dass Arzneimittel
die zum Zwecke der Abmagerung der
appetitshügelung oder der Reduzierung
des eigenen Körpergewichts eingenommen
werden von der Leistungspflicht der
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung
ausgeschlossen sind wenn also jemand wie
einnehmen möchte dann muss das aus der
eigenen Tasche bezahlt werden
Mediziner waren zudem davor das Mittel
zum loswerden kleinerer Fettpölsterchen
zu nehmen die Gefahr dahinter liegt dass
Menschen die nicht diese Erkrankung
haben dieses Medikament an Kunden und
dadurch möglicherweise eben auch
langfristig Probleme bekommen könnten
denn viele reduzieren ihr Gewicht
bereits mit einem ähnlichen Präparat
eigentlich für Diabetes Typ 2 Behandlung
vorgesehen in sozialen Medien
angepriesen abnehmen als Trend auch
Promis sind dabei trotz neuer Therapie
Menschen mit Übergewicht werden auch in
Zukunft nicht um eine Änderung des
Lebensstils herumkommen um dauerhaft
abzunehmen
in Südeuropa hält sich die Hitzewelle
Spanien schmilzt titelte ein spanischer
Online-Dienst Italien hat mittlerweile
in 23 größeren Städten die höchste
Alarmstufe wegen Hitze ausgerufen in
Griechenland kommen noch heftige
Waldbrände dazu Jürgen
Sonnenaufgang in beißenden Quallen
westlich von Athen seit drei Tagen
fressen sich die Feuer durch die waldige
Hügellandschaft mit schwerem Gerät
versuchen Feuerwehr und Armee den
Flammen die Nahrung zu entziehen
wir haben die EU um Hilfe gebeten wir
brauchen drei Einheiten die das Feuer am
Boden bekämpfen mit entsprechender
Ausrüstung
Löschflugzeug aus Italien sind schon da
Rumänien Slowakei und Polen schicken
Feuerwehrleute ganze Landstriche sind
bereits verwüstet verkohlte Wälder
zerstörte Existenzen so langsam kehren
die Bewohner die Gegend um Mandra zurück
Ernüchterung Leib und Leben gerettet
aber das Hab und Gut verloren
das Haus ist abgebrannt der Stall auch
die Tiere wurden freigelassen ein paar
sind wiedergekommen aber es gibt ja
nicht mal mehr Wasser hier
eine kleine Siedlung im Wald als das
Feuer kam haben sie ihr vergeblich auf
Hilfe gewartet
die Flammen unter Kontrolle zu halten
sie haben sich überall ausgebreitet die
Feuerwehr hat gar nichts gemacht
bei allem Zorn die Feuerwehr kann nicht
überall gleichzeitig sein immer wieder
dreht der Wind gibt den Flammen eine
neue Richtung ein ständiger Wettlauf
auch auf der vielen Insel Rhodos brennt
der Wald Feuer noch außer Kontrolle
melden die Brandbekämpfer drei Dörfer
wurden evakuiert Hitze Trockenheit Wind
das heißt höchste Brandgefahr auch in
den nächsten Tagen in Griechenland
8 Monate nach dem spektakulären
Diebstahl eines Goldschatzes im
bayerischen Manching sind vier
Verdächtige festgenommen worden in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und
Nordrhein-Westfalen weitere
Informationen will die
Staatsanwaltschaft morgen bekannt geben
die Täter waren nachts in das Kelten
Römermuseum eingebrochen und hatten fast
500 Goldmünzen aus der Zeit um 100 vor
Christus gestohlen der reine Goldwert
liegt bei etwa einer viertel Millionen
Euro ein Teil des Schatzes wurde nun
sichergestellt
er wird als Film des Jahres angepriesen
morgen startet Oppenheimer in den Kinos
ein drei Stunden hollywood-epos über
einen der Erfinder der Atombombe
prominent besetzt mit einer ganzen Riege
von Superstars kein leichter Sommerfilm
aber passen zur Zeit Andreas Stamm
dies ist ein nationaler Notstand dessen
Ende bekannt ist Wissenschaftler drücken
den Knopf zünden die erste Atombombe
Öffnen des Tor zur Hölle
1 0
im Mittelpunkt der Geschichte rund um
die atomare Stunde 0 das Leben und
Wirken des Jay robert Oppenheimer das
ist ein Wettlauf gegen die Nazis
Oppenheimer ein brillianter Physiker der
Mitte der 40er Jahre zum Leiter des
Manhattan-Projekts der USA nach der
Bombe
wir haben nur eine Hoffnung
seitdem hängt diese Bombe wie ein
damen-schwert über uns allen kurz bevor
wir zu drehen anfingen marschierte
Russland in die Ukraine ein damit ist
die Gefahr wieder sehr sehr real
geworden aber eigentlich war sie immer
da ist
Oppenheimers Ehrgeiz lässt in die
Grenzen des Möglichen verschieben
während er seine größte Angst
unterdrückt dass er und sein Team die
Apokalypse heraufbeschwören heißt es
besteht das Risiko dass wir auf dem
Knopf drücken und die ganze Welt
vernichten dieses Risiko liegt bei
national
zu null das Ensemble aus Hollywood-Stars
harmoniert in einem optisch opulenten
Film der sich an die Biografie des
Vaters der Atombombe hält einer Story
die kein extra Drama braucht
ich kann nur hoffen dass ich über die
Bedrohung Gedanken machen und
diskutieren hilft der Film liefert keine
einfachen Antworten auf all die
existenziellen Fragen die in ihm
gestellt werden die Botschaft des Films
zeitlos und eine des Grauens das
Oppenheimers Werk der Anfang vom Ende
sein könnte den Menschen die Macht
gegeben hat sich selbst zu vernichten
und die Welt ist dafür nicht bereit
mit seinen Rollen hat er
Fernsehgeschichte geschrieben Christian
quatschig ist im Alter von 78 Jahren
gestorben als zdf-landarzt Dr Matthiesen
praktizierte er bis 1992 in
Schleswig-Holstein
du hast das Vertrauen der Schleswiger
deswegen hätten sie mich auch wegen
einem Hühnerauge 30 km überland
vergessen ihre Krankenscheine ich denke
darum
spektakulär in den 70ern seine Rolle im
Tatort als Lehrer der ein Verhältnis mit
einer Minderjährigen Schülerin hatte
gespielt von nastassja Kinski auch in
unzähligen Theaterproduktionen hat er
mitgewirkt als aufschneide Jüngling oder
tragische Held
Christian quadflick
und wenn sie ihn in seiner Rolle als
Landarzt noch mal sehen wollen in
unserer Mediathek und natürlich auch
über die ZDF heute App finden Sie alle
Folgen und Geschichten aus dekelsen ab
Staffel 1
und jetzt zur Tour de France Norbert ist
wohl heute die Vorentscheidung gefallen
sieht so aus bereits gestern hatte ja
der Gesamtführende Jonas Jünger beim
Zeitfahren seinem verfolgerter die eine
regelrechte Lektion erteilt heute auf
der Königsetappe nach koschewell hat er
seinen Vorsprung eigentlich uneinholbar
ausgebaut
unfassbare 7 Minuten und 35 Sekunden
liegt der Däne jetzt vor seinem Rivalen
aus Slowenien Jonas weniger ist alleine
heute noch mal fast sechs Minuten
schneller als taddel pogaccia den
verlassen 14 km vor dem Ziel die Kräfte
sichtlich angeschlagen kann er nicht
mehr mithalten der Weg über die
Ziellinie für ihn qualvoll und
enttäuschend seinen ersten Etappen Sieg
feiert der Österreicher Felix geil der
Gesamtsieg ist dem Vorjahresgewinner
Jonas singer jetzt kaum noch zu nehmen
morgen Eröffnung der Fußball-WM am
Montag dann das erste deutsche Spiel
gegen Marokko und da haben sich die DFB
Frauen in Sachen Kapitänsbinde jetzt
festgelegt Spielführerin Alexandra Popp
wird ein Zeichen setzen gegen Gewalt an
Frauen
Alexandra Popp auf einer Mission abseits
des Fußballplatzes mit klarer Haltung
bei der Frage welche Kapitänsbinde die
Frauen Nationalelf präsentieren wird wir
haben uns für ein Thema entschieden was
wir über das ganze Turnier über
bespielen werden für die Beendigung von
Gewalt gegen Frauen einfach weil es
erstmal ein riesengroßes Thema ist
gerade was häusliche Gewalt etc und so
angeht nur diese acht Armen bieten hatte
der Weltverband zur Wahl gestellt wie
bei der Männer WM liest die FIFA die
viel diskutierte one love-binde nicht zu
das Vielfalt Thema ist unser Ding das
Bespielen wir schon seit Jahren und das
werden wir auch weiterhin
so bespielen ich denke dass es jedem
klar
für die WM bleibt Ihre Botschaft im
Zeichen der Regenbogenfarben für mehr
Diversität und Toleranz eher versteckt
auf dem abgeschirmten Trainingsplatz
das Spiel Deutschland gegen Marokko bei
uns zu sehen im ZDF am Montag um 7 Uhr
oder ab 7.30 Uhr an solche Zeiten müssen
wir uns jetzt gehören
sie lauten vier 19 25 32 33 34 und die
Superzahl 4 weitere Gewinnzahlen finden
sie auf lotto.zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf
Seite 557
es bleibt bei wechselhaftem Sommerwetter
mit Schauern die Details hat gleich
östen terli im heute journal um viertel
vor zehn spricht Christian Sievers mit
dem bayerischen Ministerpräsidenten
Söder wir sagen danke und tschüss und
wünschen Ihnen noch einen sehr schönen
Abend bis morgen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter der Jetstream
liegt derzeit quer über Europa und
dieses stark windband in etwa
neuneinhalb Kilometer Höhe trennt die
kühlere Luft im Norden von der wärmeren
teils heißen Luft im Süden und hier
herrscht hoher Luftdruck die Hitze ist
hier gefangen und wandert allmählich
auch nach Osten schauen wenn die Nacht
da gibt's im Norden und Osten Schauer
und auch Gewitter und auch im Süden das
Ganze lässt allmählich nach im Westen da
lockert es auf und die Temperaturen
sinken dort z.B auf 10 Grad und 17 Grad
in Bayern morgen dann im Norden vor
allem dann Schauer und auch mal mit
Blitz und Donner dazu kräftiger Wind aus
Nordwest in der Mitte ebenfalls Schauer
und Gewitter das Ganze lässt aber beim
Tagesfahrt auf allmählich nach so
ähnlich dann auch im Süden nach
Südwesten hin allerdings auch
Sonnenschein der länger anhält bei
höchsten Temperaturen von 17 Grad in
Schleswig-Holstein und 27 Grad z.B am
oberreiten die nächsten Tage gibt's
weitere Schauer und Gewitter vor allem
am Freitag ziemlich durchwachsen ja und
das Wochenende wird dann etwas ruhiger
und sonniger im Süden vor allem ein
schöner Abend